et avec nous pour en débattre jean paul
garraud député européen est reine tête
de liste et rennes en occitanie aux
régions aux élections régionales
justement bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
à vos côtés jacques myard mer et l'air
de maisons laffitte dans les yvelines
bonsoir jacques myard merci à vous
également d'être là donc personne ne
peut douter de ma noyauté de ma fidélité
à a dit renaud muselier cet après-midi
en tant que membre du parti les
républicains jacques myard vous le
prenez comment vous c'est une trahison
je crois qu'ils entrent et la main à
perdre parce que aujourd'hui essayer
d'aller d'élections avec elle est
réellement c'est abouti et aussi aux
wagons à perte
regardez les choses et jaune n'est pas
accroché et donc anti fini aujourd'hui
assigné pardonnez moi je suis vraiment
désolé je suis obligé d'être mal élevé
de vous couper parce que la liaison est
très mauvaise alors on va donner en
attendant la parole à jean paul garraud
en espérant vous retrouver avec un son
correct de façon à entendre ce que vous
nous dites parce que c'est très
important vous jean paul garraud
quel est votre sentiment sur cette
affaire quand vous voyez ça de
l'extérieur mais pas que parce qu'on
sait qu'il y aura des conséquences
évidemment très importante
incontournable sur votre parti le
rassemblement national notamment en paca
d'abord écouté je souhaitais simplement
c'est lui et jacques myard que je
connais très bien puisque nous avons
siéger ensemble à l'assemblée nationale
sur les mêmes bandes j'étais député ump
et si je suis où je suis aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que je suis député européen
élu sur une liste du rassemblement
national c'est parce que justement je
savais que tôt ou tard les l ère allait
arriver dans la situation dans laquelle
ils se trouvent aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'une fois de plus les nerfs se
déchirent
vous avez d'un côté dlr à qui donc qui
d'ailleurs une majorité du dlr dans mon
si je puis dire qu'ils s'allient avec
donc la république en marche parce
qu'ils sont heureux cherche disons des
postes ministériels quelques avantages
conserver le pouvoir qu'ils sont ils
estiment qu'en s'alliant avec évidemment
la république en marche il
ils vont pouvoir électoralement garder
ce qu'ils ont c'est le cas de renaud
muselier et puis vous avez une partie
non négligeable également dlr c'est
plutôt les l'air d'en bas ce sont plutôt
les adhérents les militants ce sont
plutôt ceux qui sont vraiment sur le
terrain est bien qui eux ne supporte pas
effectivement ce rapprochement avec en
marche qui sont plutôt eux qui ont
plutôt un héritage ohlins pâle un
héritage je tirais de l'ancien rpr start
et qu'ils se retrouvent leur façon dans
cette politique macro nist physique est
complètement à l'envers naturellement de
d'une politique gaulliste si je puis
dire
donc ceci fait que nous sommes dans une
situation réelle air sont dans une
situation qui les condamne à l'échec et
c'est la raison principale pour laquelle
donc je n'ai pas voulu rester dans cette
partie parce que derrière assez ces
histoires d'appareils je dirais il y a
le sort de la france et je sais très
bien que jacques myard et ceci en
premier souci ou si nous avons nous
avons souvent parlé et et nous avons les
mêmes aspirations d'ailleurs jacques
était comme septième ensemble à
l'assemblée
nous étions un peu à la droite populaire
donc que nous avions fondé avec thierry
mariani thierry mariani jacques rien
moi même donc nous étions mais d'autres
nous étions tous d'ailleurs avec plus de
40 députés de la droite populaire et on
avait créé ce mouvement la droite
populaire en 2010 pour déjà à l'époque
faire en sorte peser en quelque sorte
sur nicolas sarkozy pour ronaldo bout
des promesses électorales de 2005 donc
déjà à l'époque nous voyons bien cette
évolution de l'ump puis dlr une branche
plus tôt droite hors des organistes en
quelque sorte qu'ils se rapprochent du
centre et une autre plus bonapartiste
quelque sorte aussi qui voit bien les
problèmes de la société actuelle qui
voit bien les explosions les tensions
qui maintenant justement nous éclater à
la figure et et qui cherche
effectivement des solutions qui soient
des solutions démocratiques jacques
myard c'est parce que vous avez entendu
tontouta réponse ce soir mais et c'est
dur ce qui vous dit finalement jean paul
garraud finalement il n'avait pas le
choix ton temps ils sont retrouverez
dans cette cité jean-paul je le connais
bien il a pris effectivement une
décision d'aller dans un sens mais il
n'ya pas que paca et india pacte sont ap
personnel ce qui est en cause
en réalité c'est effectivement de passer
le premier région sont les régionales or
qu'est-ce que tu as tes vous constatez
d'une part que ça soit valérie pécresse
en région parisienne que ce soit xavier
bertrand dans le nord que ce soit
laurent wauquiez en rhône alpes
c'est qu'ils sont sur la ligne où les
élèves ce pacte sur leur drapeau et ne
vont pas faire des magouilles avec
notamment des rêves parce que c'est une
question de cohérence
c'est une question de logique
aujourd'hui est bon jean paul appui et
une voix et reviennent mais moi je sais
mes électeurs me reconnaissent en temps
le lr fort j'allais dire long terme et
aussi police depuis très longtemps et
donc je reste dans cette famille alors
thierry mariani que je peux te tiens
jean-paul que je peux mais bien ont
choisi une autre voie
je la respecte je la respecte et vous
savez là la politique conduite jamais un
long fleuve tranquille
et rien ne dit rafa se retrouver tard
lorsqu'ils auront quitté à nouveau leurs
engagements actuels et seront revenues à
diou alors on va se lancer des bas
messieurs
renaud muselier s'est défendu cet après
midi je vous propose de le réécouter on
a déjà écouté cette extrême il
l'important dans ce reportage donné déjà
des ravages
je me propose de réécouter renaud
muselier sur sur ce point qui vous
concerne peut-être jean paul garraud
région ne tombe pas aux mains d'un parti
extrémiste
j'ai fait appel au soutien le plus large
je pense que le dépassement est
impératif pour des élections locales
le premier ministre a répondu
positivement et annoncé le retrait d'une
candidature gouvernementale cette liste
sera d'abord celle de la majorité
actuelle pluriel alors évidemment c'est
votre parti jean paul garraud le rn 1
qui est clairement visé c'est une
alliance qui peut se produire dans
d'autres régions et est menacée mine de
rien vous vos candidats mais écoutez
d'abord bon je connais bien aussi renaud
muselier et j'ai beaucoup et j'ai
l'habitude d'ailleurs pour lui mais je
ne suis pas un parti extrémiste
voilà ça c'est petit si vous voulez
c'est une main c'est une sorte de
d'expressions communes qui est là
simplement pour je ne sais pas pour
cataloguer pour essayer de faire peur
jacques mauclair me connais très bien
chez les chalets étaient excessifs en
quoi que ce soit je suis magistrat
pendant 30 ans j'ai vu j'ai été sur le
terrain et j'ai tellement
monter ce qui allait nous arriver que
j'ai pris la décision que j'ai prise
justement pour la france en fait et je
sais que fondamentalement nous pensons
la même chose et c'est cela il faut
trouver une solution à ses ouvriers en
occitanie que je suis à présent et bien
déjà en 2015 nous avions avec les
républicains le rassemblement national
fnj front national à l'époque et les
républicains nous sommes à 55 % en 2015
au jour d'aujourd'hui nous sommes
certainement encore plus haut eh bien à
chaque fois on se débrouille pour perdre
alors qu'on est majoritaire et c'est
exactement la même chose dans le pays
alors si au lait se serait pas très
grave si c'était uniquement des
histoires d'appareils mais derrière
c'est la politique de la france qui en
pâtit et moi ce que je dis simplement
c'est que je ne demande pas à ce que
tout le monde vienne ou rassemblement
national pas du tout moi même d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas ma carte au rassemblement
national mais ce que je demande
simplement si qu'on ne s'interdisent pas
des alliances les alliances électorales
c'est à dire ce que la gauche ils font
depuis très longtemps le piège
mitterrandien à fonctionne toujours
c'est extraordinaire françois mitterrand
donc avait sorti à l'époque mais c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque ce n'était pas le
rassemblement de national d'aujourd'hui
mais ça fonctionne toujours
ce rejet cet ostracisme ce qui consiste
à faire peur à barrer la route à une
sorte de mouvement qui serait
antidémocratique c'est faux le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui
honnêtement je ne vois pas de différence
avec le rpr chargé à quelques cultures
connu voilà donc évidemment ceci n'est
pas n'est pas évolué et nous avons aussi
des programmes beaucoup de choses donc
jacques merger vous faire la guerre mais
justement sur ces petits arrangements
entre amis là je vous taquine un peu
mais enfin emmanuel macron on doit
certainement se frotter les mains de son
côté écouter ce qu'on dit gabriel
atta le porte parole du gouvernement en
vendre vous fait réagir jacques myard
c'est dans notre adn
on s'est engagé en 2010 est derrière
l'idée du dépassement politique et le
fait que les hommes et femmes ne sont
pas prisonniers derrière des étiquettes
politiques et on assiste aujourd'hui à
une nouvelle étape de ce dépassement au
niveau local mais aussi à une
clarification au niveau national pour
les républicains
jacques myard clairement c'est ce que
vous craignez parce que gabriel attal
son temps qu'on est dans une nouvelle
étape et qui en aura d'autres je vais
vous dire je vais vous dire une chose
monsieur attal vie et dans je dirais une
sorte de mythe qui n'existe pas pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui les gens qui me
sont pris avec eux au gouvernement ne
représente rien
qu'est ce que représente sur le plan
électoral bruno le maire rien qu'est ce
que représente monsieur darmanin rien
ils n'ont pas de base électorale ce qui
peut se passer pour gouverner la france
c'est effectivement une question de
projet politique et ce projet politique
il est clair que je peux avoir du site
et de souveraineté de politique
industrielle sécurité d'indépendance de
la politique étrangère partager avec
d'autres
mais je les défends après est ce que je
suis et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle compte tenu de ce que pensent
mais les électeurs qui m'ont élu je
reste fidèle à pons drapeau alors
maintenant est ce que ça veut dire que
les choses vont rester habitable en état
je n'en sais rien mais il est possible
effectivement que monsieur garraud
rejoignent et souverainistes boulistes
peu mou mois pour qu'on puisse continuer
le combat et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne lance pas d'anathème
indicateurs ont pris une autre voie
mais je leur dis attention c'est qu'il
faudra gouverner la france avec des gens
qui tiennent la barre
je suis sûr que mon avis garraud est
capable de remplir des missions
je ne suis pas sûr que tous aux airelles
soit capable de tenir
bah alors la réponse de jean paul
garraud dit votre avis mais non mais
écoutez c'est très simple je suis
d'accord avec ce que dit jacques bien
sur le fond sur le fond on est
totalement d'accord il a évoqué la
souveraineté bien entendu il à la place
de la france à la sécurité l'identité
notre histoire enfin tout ce qui est
battue en brèche aujourd'hui donc l'idée
l'idée quand même c'est de gagner
d'arriver à gagner dagany ensemble
marine le pen est la première à dire
qu'il faut un gouvernement d'union
nationale avec des gens qui ne jette pas
des anathèmes avec des gens qui sont
évidemment qu'ils ont les mêmes
réflexions que nous et qui voit bien
qu'il faut arriver au pouvoir c'est
absolument vital
alors moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
jacques mais il sait très bien qu'il
n'ya pas de candidat actuellement qui
est capable de remporter l'élection
présidentielle dans le mouvement
l air que lui chacun représente je parle
dlr qui sont pas ma crown compatibles
parce que je sais que jacques lien n'est
pas du tout macro compatible bon donc
kiki aux républicains est en position
aujourd'hui de gagner je tombe bien
gagner la présidentielle
et bien malheureusement il n'y a
personne malheureusement pour les
républicains
donc il faut faire un peu de politique
de réaliste moi je demande simplement à
ce qu'on me croit là où je suis
aujourd'hui je travaille avec des gens
intéressants avec les cheveux je fais de
vrais programmes
je construis de vrais programmes par
exemple en ce qui nous concerne et bien
j'ai mis en place donc le livre blanc
sur la sécurité sur la justice j'y viens
on place le contre projet sur
l'islamisme
ce sont des sujets sur lesquels j'ai
toujours travaillé toujours y compris
quand j'étais et chacun le sait très
bien et y compris quand j'étais
évidemment à l'ump
malheureusement on n'est pas arrivé là
où on aurait souhaité surtout quand au
long de monsieur hollande est arrivé
avec madame taubira
ils ont tous mis par terre de ce qu'on
avait pu faire et puis on n'était pas
allé peut-être jusqu'au bout pour un
certain nombre de raisons au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'urgence qui
gouverne
donc c'est parra - devenir c'est jacques
et qui doit venir vers nous ce sera on
en arrive à mon goût du débat très
rapidement gagner gagner alors c'est
très simple on va franchir le cap des
régionales et il y aura un candidat ou
je suis d'accord avec jean paul sait
qu'il peut pas y en avoir deux et donc
pour arriver à redresser la barre il va
falloir qu'il y ait un candidat ait
l'air et croyez moi c'est possible on a
des hommes de talent est là jean-paul
reviendra doux et des femmes de talent
j'imagine aussi merci après les
régionales merci en tout cas vous d'eux
jean paul garraud et jacques myard
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france